seit juni sind die züge ziemlich voll
dank des neuen euro tickets es macht das
reisen in deutschland erschwinglich für
alle in wenigen tagen jedoch ist damit
schluss ein nachfolger des 9 euro
tickets würde den staat viel geld kosten
spd chef lars klingbeil gestern in
seinem wahlkreis in bispingen unterwegs
hat eine idee woher das geld kommen
könnte
ein möglicher weg ist die über gewinn
steuer die helfen würde dass wir den
sozialen zusammenhalt in diesem land
auch sichern wir brauchen eine nachfolge
für das neue euro ticket das hat
funktioniert viele menschen sind auf
öffentliche nahverkehrsmittel
umgestiegen und da sind wir als spd der
meinung dass diejenigen die jetzt
milliarden gewinne machen dass die ein
bisschen was abgeben können dass man die
stärker besteuern kann seit dem
einmarsch russlands in die ukraine
fahren energiekonzerne weltweit
rekordgewinne ein während die menschen
unter preissteigerungen leiden auch
europäische ölmultis machen kasse zuvor
shell allein im zweiten quartal
2022 einen gewinn von 11,5 milliarden
dollar ein im vorjahresquartal waren es
5,5 milliarden total energies verdiente
9,8 milliarden fast dreimal so viel wie
vor einem jahr waren es 3,5 auch bp
verdreifachte seinen gewinn auf 9,3
milliarden im vergleich zu 3,1 vor einem
jahr
diese drei ölmultis betreiben in
deutschland 5412 tankstellen und
verdienen auch in deutschland sehr viel
mehr geld
vor einer woche legten das netzwerk
steuergerechtigkeit und die den linken
nahestehende rosa-luxemburg-stiftung
eine studie zur über gewinnsteuern vor
sie fand große beachtung sein ansatz um
über gewinner zu ermitteln ist dass man
die aktuelle rendite in der krisenzeit
mit der rendite mit deinen
anführungszeichen normalen rendite aus
der vorkrisenzeit vergleicht ein ansatz
den wohl auch robert habeck verfolgt
denn auch die grünen sind für die
einführung einer über gewinn steuer wenn
unternehmen darüber hinaus gute über
gewinne gemacht haben der die debatte zu
führen ob diese über gewinne nicht in
dieser situation der finanzierung oder
der abhilfe der finanzierung durch
finanzierung von not- oder armut zu gute
kommen sollen sie wissen dass ich das
richtig finde
finanzminister christian lindner jedoch
lehnt eine über gewinn steuer
kategorisch ab
dafür würden wir aber die
rechtssicherheit in deutschland in
unserem steuersystem in frage stellen
das heißt ohne etwas zu erreichen würden
wir einen standortvorteil unseres landes
nämlich eine berechenbare
marktwirtschaftliche ordnung in frage
stellen deshalb kann man nur davor
warnen solche debatten weiter
fortzusetzen der bundesfinanzminister
warnt vor etwas was die eu-kommission
längst empfiehlt bereits im märz
beschließt sie dringlichkeit maßnahmen
zu energiepreisen und gasspeicherung und
legt fest dass mitgliedstaaten einnahmen
aus den hohen gewinnen des
energiesektors und aus dem
emissionshandel an die verbraucher um
verteilen können
belgien großbritannien italien
griechenland rumänien ungarn und spanien
führen gerade über gewinnsteuern ein
oder wollen sie einführen
in spanien soll der nahverkehr ab erster
september vier monate lang kostenlos
sein bezahlt mit einnahmen aus einer
über gewinn steuer für banken und
energieunternehmen
außerdem sollen 12.000 neue wohnungen
damit gebaut werden allerdings
die großen unternehmen in diesem land
die oligopole verfügen über die besten
anwälte die es mit dem staat aufnehmen
und die oft gewinnen es ist absolut
sicher dass die betroffenen konzerne die
neuen steuern juristisch anfechten
werden
in großbritannien müssen
energieunternehmen eine sondersteuer von
25 prozent der gewinne zahlen
finanzminister regie so nack will
dadurch 5 milliarden pfund einnehmen und
damit die verbraucher entlasten so
genannte wind
vortagsgewinne die vom himmel fallen
führt großbritannien nicht zum ersten
mal ein
bereits anfang der 80er jahre besteuerte
margaret thatcher ikone der
konservativen die über gewinne von
banken und öl firmen mit erfolg
es ist eine steuer die funktioniert und
sie schreckt auch keine investoren ab
wichtig für die firmen es ist eine
einmalige steuer nicht für immer für
einen kurzen zeitraum und für eine
bestimmte größe des gewinns
in italien beschloss die regierung im
mai eine einmalige abgabe von 25 prozent
für energiefirmen die von steigenden öl
und gaspreisen profitieren die meisten
öl konzerne zahlen aber einfach nicht
und spielen auf zeit
mario draghi nur noch bis ende september
regierungschef kritisiert die branche
dafür
jetzt wo die meisten italienischen
familien und firmen in schwierigkeiten
sind gibt es einen sektor der eine
staatliche bestimmung umgeht das ist
nicht tolerierbar
im november müssen die ölkonzerne zahlen
sonst werden strafen fällig
das italienische modell ein vorbild für
deutschland
die wissenschaftlichen dienste des
bundestages untersuchten die
verfassungsmäßigkeit einer über gewinn
steuer nach italienische modell und
kommen zum schluss der bund kann durch
gesetz eine ergänzungsabgabe zur
einkommensteuer und zur
körperschaftsteuer erheben
deswegen noch mal mein plädoyer die über
gewinn steuer einzuführen um den
demokratischen zusammenhalt in diesem
land zu stärken die debatte um über
gewinnsteuern in deutschland geht weiter